it was September 2006 and I found myself
sitting in a New York City Starbucks
waiting for someone I'd never met before
a couple months earlier I put my job at
the big Manhattan law firm and decided
to set out and explore new career
opportunities in doing so I jumped feet
first into the New York City tech scene
I started attending tech meetups and
going to networking events tryna just
get to know as many people in the space
that could in the process I met a
computer programmer who after hearing my
interests offered to connect me with
another person that he had recently met
it was in a similar exploratory phase of
his career so I accepted and here I was
City the Starbucks waiting for this
person Dan to arrive about 15 minutes
after I got there Dan showed up we
exchanged pleasantries we grabbed our $5
cups of coffee sat down and had what
ended up being the first of dozens of
conversations at this same Starbucks
where we swap business ideas shared
resources and generally supported one
another in our entrepreneurial efforts
my relationship with Dan over the next
seven years really influenced much of my
subsequent business success and really
solidified my belief in the power of a
strong network my name is TJ Duane I'm
an extrovert I love meeting new people
over the last 35 years
I've accumulated a lot of education and
my wife hopes that this is my last
degree but in the process I've really
come to appreciate that my education has
only done a little bit to bring me to
this point to influence my success the
people I know and those in my network
really have brought me here today it's
not what you know it's who you know it's
not always what you know it's who you
know
in fact I imagine that most of us here
in this room today are at the GSB
because we share this sentiment a lot of
us were probably motivated to come here
to broaden our professional network
however while we may recognize the value
in a strong Network sometimes we don't
always know how to do it well for
introverts networking can be a
terrifying proposition it can be
paralyzing networking situations really
can be hard to get through and they need
a lifeline to pull them along for
extroverts like me networking also has
it challenges I for one sometimes in a
little too confident in networking
situations and that is causing to step
on some some landmines along the way so
over the last 15 years I've spoken with
hundreds of students and professionals
about networking and in the process
identified a few strategies that I've
seen others use that I've tried to
employ myself some of these are like
lines that have helped me through
situations and I think would help
introverts through similar situations
others are landmines that I
unfortunately have stepped on from time
to time so I hope you'll let me share a
few of these with you today probably
those fundamental thing about a
networking interaction the first thing
that I try and do is establish a common
connection a similarity people like to
be around those who are similar to them
for introverts I usually do that sort of
for introverts the lifeline here is
identifying something early in the
conversation something you may have in
common with the other person and
establishing a connection on that
whether it's you know you've traveled to
the United Arab Emirates or you you know
you've worked in microfinance this
Harshman and and Rob have or whatever it
may be find that connection early
establish that similarity and it'll make
you memorable for that person it's
something that I value the landmine here
for extroverts is being a bit too
confident or too comfortable or making
assumptions too early I used to have a
colleague who was recently divorced and
would start out engagements or
interactions by mentioning that fact
thinking it would like engender sympathy
let's just say it was a bit awkward next
be centered you know be focused be in
the moment
all too often we're in networking
situations and there's a lot a lot else
going on in fact you know just last
evening I was having coffee with Camilla
and we were in town square and there
were so many people walking around that
I would find myself sort of looking over
her shoulder glancing around the
landmine that's a real landmine you know
don't be
don't take your attention from the
person that you're engaging with don't
wave and nod at someone walking by it
shows that you're not really in the
moment like one here or introverts could
be you know taking the person's name
remembering their name appreciating who
you're talking to and using their name
in the conversation it will show that
you're you care and that you're you're
in the moment and you're focused in
addition you know listening to their
story why are we in these networking
situations we're in these networking
situations because we want to broaden
you know the people that we know and
Huson add value to our careers and our
lives so you want to know how this
person's gonna be able to add value to
you you want to listen to their story
and sometimes it's hard for people to
tell their story
so the lifeline here is you know ask
questions sincere questions draw out
their story their expertise identify
ways that they'll be able to add value
for you the landmine here as I've been
known to do in the past is asking too
many questions this is a conversation
it's a networking interaction it's not
an interview and on occasion I may have
veered into the realm of interrogation
definitely not an interrogation I've
been talking people who've hit me with
like gunfire questions one after another
it's a little bit of a turn-off and I
know I've done it myself so that's it's
something totally in addition to
listening to their story and seeing how
they can add value to your network you
want to make it clear how you're gonna
add value to their network why do people
network again it's to see how they can
broaden their influence and
and the value that people can add so in
speaking with someone a lifeline here is
you know telling your story getting it
into the conversation you know talking
about your experience your expertise
your education the different things that
you know that may be valuable to them
the landmine of course is telling your
story too enthusiastically sometimes
sometimes talking about your expertise
and your experience can come across as
bragging we've all talked to people who
early on in the interaction with them
they talked about all the great places
they visited and the houses they owned
and the cars they owned and all this
expertise they have and it can be a bit
of a turn-off so be mindful that fifth
just as important is starting out the
conversation by established by
establishing similarity is booked ending
the conversation
with a follow-up lifeline and following
up and following through a lifeline here
clearances try to identify something in
the conversation where you can add
immediate value you know think of when
personally when you're talk with the
person think of a way that you me may be
able to make a connection for them
straight away much the same way that
computer program I did with me and Dan
seven years ago if you can add value
immediately do it if not you can add
value
soon after do that as well one thing I
like to do is if I'm reading a newspaper
article or seeing a you know I see a
product that I know someone in my
network may be interested in I'll go
ahead and send it to them in fact you
know just yesterday Sabrina and I met
with the CLO over Evernote and I was
great great meeting was for a class
project and this morning in the Wall
Street Journal there was a quote from
the the co-founder the chips for the
co-founder of the charter schools hip
charter schools saying how he loved
Evernote it was his favorite app I was
the one to use all the time so what I do
this morning I shot an email off to the
CLO saying hey look you got some you got
a nice shout out in The Wall Street
Journal this morning it shows people
that you were in the moment in that
networking engagement you're thinking
about them and you're you know you're
being mindful about what they may need
and you're showing how again you can add
value following through is super
important we've all been in situations
where someone says they're gonna do
something and they don't someone says
they're gonna call and they don't that
doesn't work in the dating world doesn't
work in the networking world don't over
promise and under deliver follow up
follow through so these are just a few
strategies to help make networking
situations one-on-one networking
situations a little bit easier a
big-picture networking isn't
transactional it's not about numbers
it's not about how many LinkedIn
connections you have or how many
Facebook friends you have networking is
about building real relationships
relationships where you add value and
the other person adds value for you I
didn't know seven years ago when I sat
down with Dan that first time that the
conversations we were gonna have and the
ventures we were gonna work on together
would one day lead me to stand here
today but they did and the relationship
with Dan and dozens others over the
years have put me in a position to be
able to speak with you this
for some of you in the room maybe a
little shocked more shy I hope some of
these landmines that I discussed will
help make the next networking
interaction for you a bit more
comfortable for some of you who are
extrovert seen maybe a bit overzealous
like myself I help talking about some of
the landmines I've stepped on will prove
cautionary in the end when we're
finished with the GSB we'll all have
accumulated a lot of Education long know
a lot and although that education will
take us a certain distance the people we
know those in our network the
relationships we've built will determine
our ultimate success thank you